what are my favorite top five movies for
entrepreneurs
I'm going to answer that question in
today's episode of luncheon urn so we
also got asked a question from one of my
YouTube viewers love you guys
Moroccan gamer geek who wrote in to say
can you talk about some motivational
movies please or just write them down if
you don't have time so I had a hard time
with this one and was starting to think
which are the movies that I really love
and enjoy because I get a lot out of
movies and almost every move that I
watch I'm always thinking about my
business in my life and try to pull a
piece of it that I might be able to
apply but for this video I'm gonna share
with you the five ones that have had I
think the biggest impact on my business
number one is job starring Ashton
Kutcher and this movie came to me at the
right time I was always a Steve Jobs fan
but I was going through a time at the
moment in my life was trying to figure
out what am I staying for with my
business what are the big things I want
to accomplish I was trying to find my
one word what eventually became my one
were to believe and I saw the movie
first with my wife and then I saw it
with a colleague of mine and a friend
and after watching that movie the first
time I made the decision that I need to
go out and do something bigger it really
inspired me to want to do something more
I wanted people to hit my website and
watch my videos and respond with my
social media posts and feel feel
something that matters I wanted
everybody to come away from every video
that they watch inspired and wanted to
take action because that was the feeling
I got from leaving that movie and I
wanted to be able to instill that in
other people and immediately I made
appointments with two friends of mine
and wanted to do a big project with them
and I didn't wait until you know the
next night or the next day I did it on
the spot leaving the theater while I had
my my moment of boldness and watching a
movie and I said that means with both of
them and one of them came on board the
other one didn't work out one of them
came on board and and has been an
amazing contributor to my business sense
and so it's one of my all-time favorite
movies for entrepreneurs number two for
me was Pursuit of Happyness starring
Will Smith and that movie really taught
me about not giving up he was a guy who
was faced with incredible laws and Chris
Gardner in
he was a single dad and he was homeless
and trying to look after son and try to
just build a positive life and he wanted
to be a stockbroker and you know just
got kicked and punched in the gut over
and over and over and over again and
just stuck to his dream and never gave
up and eventually turned it around
became a millionaire it started living
his life you know built a dream life for
himself and you know no matter what
you're going through right now in your
life it probably is not as bad as what
Chris Gardner had from going from a
homeless single dad and if he could
stick on his dream and he could continue
to plow through every single day just
gives me the courage and the motivation
inspiration say I can do it too
and hopefully you can as well so I
highly recommend watching that movie
number three is Moneyball and that stars
Brad Pitt and I was a fan of the book by
Michael Lewis and what it teaches you is
to be creative and to think outside the
box and do things that are different
because you are forced to be constrained
by your resources it's a story of Billy
Beane who's a general manager of the
Oakland Athletics and it was a team that
had very little money and they're trying
to compete with the New York Yankees and
that the big the big teams in baseball
and they couldn't do it by out spending
and I think it's it's the same thing
with you as an entrepreneur right you've
got your business you're taking on the
New York Yankees in your industry the
big players you're not going to do it by
taking out Super Bowl commercials and by
investing a lot of money in magazine
advertising in TV ads right you can't do
it the same way they do it and so the
lack of resources forces you to be
creative and think outside the zone and
so that's what I really loved about it
was very entrepreneurial to me and one
of my favorite movies
number four is any given Sunday and the
movie itself is just okay but it's
famous to this one epic speech by Al
Pacino
that I remember when I had my company
and I was struggling I would have that
on at least once a day to get me fired
up and excited to go out and do
something important with my business I
had a business partner at the time in
that company and we would recite the
lines to each other and it just was a
fun way to keep ourselves motivated and
amped up and I think the movie itself
again was just okay but it's worth
watching just that one clip of Al Pacino
if you need some motivation to get going
for the day
number five is Seabiscuit and that's
because the movie is all about believe
it's about this horse that was supposed
to do well that never did well and was
just thrown in cast aside it's about
this trainer that used to be a champion
and that nobody wanted to deal with it's
about this jockey that is too big that
nobody thinks going to be a jockey it's
about this owner that is down on his
luck and all of these people who
everybody has discounted and said there
has been xand they're never going to
make it find each other somehow and then
create history by winning a whole bunch
of races and it's based on a true story
and I've seen that movie probably thirty
times it's my favorite movie and I
encourage you to go check it out all
about believe and it's called Seabiscuit
and before wrapping up I wanted to
quickly talk about one movie called
boiler room and when I was a younger
entrepreneur I loved this movie but it's
come off my list I liked how Ben Affleck
came in and would tell the sales
associates about selling and you would
say what did he say he said that a sale
is always made he would say that either
you convince somebody why they need to
buy from you or they convince you on a
reason why they don't need to either way
a sale is made and that got me all
excited and fired up and I thought that
was how you did business through cold
calling and forcing people to buy from
you and convincing them that you had the
right product for them and as I've grown
older I've come to understand that it's
not like that
almost at all and that's one of the
least effective ways to actually grow
your business and so it's fallen off my
top-five list so I hope that helped
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know from you what is your
favorite movie that all entrepreneurs
must watch leave it in the comments
below I'm curious to find out and I'm
gonna join in the discussion thank you
so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon